[Musique]
toujours deux pas derrière
il aura passé la majorité de sa vie dans
l'ombre de la reine elizabeth ii homme
dur selon certains cocasse pour d'autres
le prince philip était peut-être l'un
des personnages les plus difficiles à
cerner de buckingham palace mais prince
de grèce et du danemark en 1921 il
quitte l'île de corfou en catastrophe
alors qu'il n'a qu'un an et demi la
monarchie y vient de tomber sa famille
se réfugie en france
sa mère souffre de schizophrénie son
père part vivre à monaco le jeune prince
se destine à une carrière militaire ou
devient aussi un athlète accompli
à 18 ans il s'engage dans la marine
anglaise et rencontrent pour la première
fois elisabeth venu visiter le collège
laval
la jeune princesse n'a alors que 13 ans
c'est le coup de foudre le couple
entretient une correspondance jusqu'à la
seconde guerre mondiale
[Musique]
philippe combat pendant six ans sur les
hauts d'europe et d'asie à son retour en
1946 le jeune prince et premier
lieutenant d'un 10 3 hier et n'a pas
oublié elizabeth
pendant des mois ils se fréquentent mais
le mariage semble impossible si l'ip n'a
plus de tron et l'entourage de la
princesse craint que le jeune homme au
franc parler ne respecte pas le
protocole mais le public séduit en
décidera autrement
en novembre 1947 leur rêve se réalise un
an plus tard charles voit le jour mais
leur bonheur est de courte durée
le roi georges 6 meur elisabeth accède
au trône
à seulement 27 ans est le lot de notre
pécule pour philips couronnement
signifie la fin de sa carrière militaire
et contrairement aux femmes de souverain
il ne pourra jamais devenir
le prince devra se contenter d'un rôle
secondaire et surtout d'être le plus
discret possible
il portera le titre de prince consort
avec ses nombreuses gaffes il faut pas
le prince amusé des anglais certains
diront qu'il avait un charme indéniable
d'ailleurs les journaux à potins vont
rapporter plusieurs frasques amoureuses
hors mariage
mais pour beaucoup le prince philip
était un homme de principes qu'ils
croyaient en la famille et qui a fini
par avoir le respect des britanniques en
mai 2010 est à 95 ans il s'est retiré de
la vie publique
il était le soutien indéfectible de la
reine ici à 0 déguerpissent radio canada
montréal